[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Serien in allen einen schönen
guten Abend Katja Fußball Deutschland
ist enttäuscht bis verunsichert und
viele sogar äußerst ratlos inklusive
Bundestrainer schönen guten Abend dann
blicken wir jetzt auf die Themen an
diesem Mittwoch
sind die Klimaziele noch zu erreichen
die Bundesregierung weicht das
Klimaschutzgesetz auf und erntet dafür
deutliche Kritik
hemmungslose Familienclans nach
Ausschreitungen im Ruhrgebiet fragt sich
die Politik was zu tun ist
und Ratlosigkeit wohin man schaut nach
der nächsten Pleite des DFB-Teams zählt
Sportdirektor Rudi Völler die Spieler an
Trainer haben sie fliegt darf bleiben
[Musik]
40 Umweltverbände haben sich
zusammengetan warnen und kritisieren
Schaf und zwar die heute vom
Bundeskabinett beschlossenen Änderungen
am Klimaschutzgesetz entstanden sind die
Aufweichungen auf Druck der FDP in
Zukunft soll es etwa keine verbindlichen
Klimaziele mehr für einzelne
regierungsressource geben bislang ist es
ja so verfehlt ein Bereich wie Energie
Landwirtschaft Industrie oder Verkehr
wegen zu viel Treibhausgasen des
Klimaziel muss er Sofortmaßnahmen
vorlegen mit der Reform müssen künftig
alle Bereiche zusammen die Klimaziele
erreichen heißt konkret zu viele
Treibhausgase im Verkehr können etwa
durch Einsparungen bei der Industrie
ausgeglichen werden über diesen
Kompromiss und die Kritik daran Patrizia
Wiedemeier
Augen zu und nichts hören ausgerechnet
der Kanzler der im Wahlkampf mit
Klimaschutz warb und der grüne
klimaminister weichen das seit
dreieinhalb Jahren geltende
Klimaschutzgesetz auf für etwa 40
Umweltverbände nicht akzeptabel Proteste
am Morgen vor dem Kanzleramt die
Bundesregierung ist angetreten um
wirksamen Klimaschutz umzusetzen diesem
Anspruch hängen sie aber weit hinterher
und statt diese Lücke jetzt zu schließen
drehen sie an der an ihren
Verpflichtungen an den Bilanzierungen
damit sie bis ans Ende dieser
Legislaturen nicht mehr zum Handeln
gezwungen werden kann denn künftig muss
die Bundesregierung insgesamt gegen
steuern wenn die Klimaziele verfehlt
werden so hat es das Kabinett
beschlossen aber nur wenn der
Treibhausgas Ausstoß in zwei
aufeinanderfolgenden Jahren zu hoch war
die jährlichen Sektor Ziele werden
abgeschafft eine Verwässerung die vor
allem auf Druck der FDP zustande kam
kein Wunder es ist vor allem der
Verkehrsbereich der die Klimaziele
verfehlt
dem Verkehrsminister jedoch ihm reichen
seine bisherigen Maßnahmen viele Dinge
tragen ja schon Früchte der Hochlauf der
Elektromobilität die Umstellung von
Fahrzeugflotten im Lieferverkehr oder
das deutschland-
Millionen neue Abonnenten und Abonnenten
im ÖPNV gebracht hat ein Tempolimit für
den Klimaschutz lehnt die FDP dagegen
weiterhin ab für die Opposition
insgesamt ein Rückschritt
das Herzstück des klimaschutzgesetzes
ist die Pflicht sofort nachzubessern
wenn eine Lücke entstanden ist damit die
Lücke nicht größer wird und genau diese
Pflicht wird es abgeschafft damit wird
Klimaschutz in die Zukunft verschoben
jetzt bleibt es die Aufgabe des
Parlaments das Klimaschutzgesetz noch zu
verbessern keine leichte Aufgabe
ja das Bundeskabinett hat heute noch
etwas in Sachen Klima und Umweltschutz
beschlossen eine Reform des
Straßenverkehrsgesetzes ökologische und
gesundheitliche schutzaspekte spielen
dabei eine größere Rolle dafür sollen
die Kommunen mehr Spielraum für eigene
Entscheidungen bekommen so können Sie
zum Beispiel Tempo 30 Zonen in der Nähe
von Spielplätzen oder Schulen leichter
einrichten genauso wie sonderfahrspuren
für alternativ betriebene Busse oder
Fahrzeuge mit mehreren Menschen
400 Milliarden Dollar so hoch schätzt
die Weltbank die Kosten für den
Wiederaufbau der Ukraine auf einer
Konferenz in London haben
Regierungsvertreter aus 61 Ländern heute
beraten und Geld gesammelt sie forderten
vor allem die Privatwirtschaft auf in
der Ukraine zu investieren staatliche
Hilfen sollen neben der Infrastruktur
auch in die Bekämpfung der Korruption
fließen die deutsche Außenministerin
Werbung sagte Ziel sei der Wiederaufbau
einer EU tauglichen Ukraine
ja während der Westen über den
Wiederaufbau berät die EU sich auf das
inzwischen elfte Sanktionspaket gegen
Russland einigte wird die Infrastruktur
in der Ukraine weiter zerstört oder
steht unter Beschuss
100.000 Haushalte in Kiew waren heute
ohne Strom was der vor zwei Wochen
zerstörte kachowka Staudamm in der
Südukraine für das Leben und Arbeiten
der Menschen bedeutet zeigt jetzt Alisa
jung
Wasser als Waffe am Stausee am kochhofer
Damm fehlt inzwischen so viel dass hier
in majanske kein Schiff mehr anlegen
kann das neue getreideterminal hatte vor
dem Krieg 200.000 Tonnen in einem Jahr
von hier aus in die Welt geliefert der
Plan war eigentlich das Getreide hier
mit Schiffen abzutransportieren und
damit viel Geld für Logistik zu sparen
der Standort hat erst 2021 eröffnet und
ist jetzt ohne Wasser und mit
beschädigten Silos nicht mehr zu
betreiben russische Truppen auf der
anderen Uferseite haben sie hier schon
mehrfach beschossen
stabilos sind durchlöchert nicht mehr zu
benutzen das ist die Zerstörung von
allem damit weder die
landwirtschaftliche Infrastruktur oder
irgendeine andere
infrastrukturfunktionsfähig ist sie
zerstören alles damit wir hier so hart
wie möglich Überleben der Krieg
vernichtet ihre Lebensgrundlage eine
Katastrophe sagt zachipitaschewski und
wird langfristige Folgen haben durch die
Überschwemmung sind die Ernten kaputt
die Trinkwasserversorgung in vielen
Orten lahmgelegt durch die Angriffe
viele Wohnhäuser und Infrastruktur
zerstört in komischowa haben sie Angst
dass es nach dem Krieg nicht mehr viele
Gründe gibt in die Ukraine
zurückzukehren das Dorf ist 20 km von
der Frontlinie entfernt alle Fabriken
wurden hier zerschossen
die Lebensbedingungen wiederherstellen
die Infrastruktur aufbauen so dass es
hier nicht schlechter ist als im Ausland
wenn es keine Arbeit mehr gibt keine
Möglichkeit en das Leben zu bestreiten
wird auch die Zukunft nach dem Krieg
eine unsichere
Raub Geldwäsche Drogenhandel gegen Clan
Kriminalität also kriminelle Mitglieder
von Großfamilien kämpft die Polizei ja
seit Jahren
deutschlandweit gab es 2021 dazu 47
Ermittlungsverfahren 19 also rund 40
Prozent davon allein in
Nordrhein-Westfalen die Polizei
registrierte hier fast 5.500 Straftaten
nach den Massenschlägerei in den
Castrop-Rauxel und Essen heute
Sondersitzung im Düsseldorfer Landtag
Dominik Müller Russell
macht eure tiktok-apps zu und kommt mit
Blut trinken angestachelt von solchen
Gewalt aufrufen ziehen letzten Freitag
rund 200 libanesisch ständige Männer
durch die Essener Innenstadt ihr Ziel
ein syrisches Restaurant dass sie
verwüsten und dabei auch mehrere
Menschen verletzten bereits am Vortag
prügeln in benachbarten Castrop-Rauxel
Libanesen und Syrer aufeinander ein
bewaffnet mit Dachlatten und Messern
dabei hatte sich NRWs Innenminister
Herbert Reul den Kampf auch gegen solche
Clan Kriminalität auf die Fahnen
geschrieben er betont heute die Anzahl
solcher tumulierte ging zurück in NRW
und wird sich dagegen zu wenig zu tun
30 Jahre lang hat die Politik gepennt
hat sich keiner gekümmert wir sind jetzt
seit fünf Jahren dran wir kriegen
Fortschritte hin und ich glaube das ist
ein Fortschritt das ist ein Teilschritt
nach vorne aber es ist noch lange nicht
genug aber zu sagen der jetzt nichts
bewegt das ist wirklicher Quark auch in
anderen Bundesländern sind Kriminelle
Clans immer wieder im Fokus der
Ermittler die bundesinnenministerin
kündigt heute an gemeinsam mit den
Ländern eine Allianz gegen Clan
Kriminalität bilden zu wollen ich glaube
diese Gemeinsamkeit bei den
finanzermittlung bei dem Vorgehen bei
dem starken Polizeipräsenz zeigen wird
insgesamt helfen diese furchtbare Art
der Kriminalität zu bekämpfen der
Experte Ralf Kartbahn beobachtet seit
Jahrzehnten die Strukturen solcher Clans
schnelle Lösungen sieht er nicht wir
haben bis jetzt kein Konzept für die
Integration von hermetischen Gruppen die
sich selber von unserer Gesellschaft
abgrenzt die Essener Polizei versucht
nun einzelne Straftäter zu ermitteln und
sie will mir Präsenz zeigen damit sich
solche aufmarsche nicht wiederholen
sie wissen in der corona-zeit gab es
diverse Einschränkungen nicht immer zu
Recht sagt jetzt das
Bundesverwaltungsgericht so hätte das
Land Sachsen zu Beginn der
pandemieversammlungen nicht pauschal
verbieten dürfen das Gericht vermisster
eine klare Regelung die Ausnahmen
ermöglicht hätte prinzipiell war die
Beschränkung der Versammlungsfreiheit
aber zulässig
unter anderem wegen Verbrechen gegen die
Menschlichkeit und Beihilfe zum
Völkermord ist eine is Anhängerin in
Koblenz verurteilt worden zu einer
Haftstrafe von 9 Jahren und drei Monaten
das Oberlandesgericht sah es als
erwiesen an dass sich die deutsche 2014
der Terrororganisation islamischer Staat
angeschlossen hatte in ihrer Zeit in
Syrien und dem Irak habe sie eine junge
Jesidin wie eine Sklavin im Haushalt
gehalten dass ihr syrischer Ehemann das
Opfer regelmäßig vergewaltigte habe sie
ermöglicht anstatt es zu verhindern
neues Thema für die Energieversorgung
der Zukunft sucht Deutschland ja neue
Partner viele Hoffnungen weckt dabei
Kasachstan die ehemalige Sowjetrepublik
strebt ihrerseits nach mehr
Unabhängigkeit von Moskau und wirbt um
ausländische Investoren und so langsam
wird es konkret Bundespräsident
Steinmeier und deutsche
Wirtschaftsvertreter sind vor Ort und
Lars bodensack dabei noch lässt es sich
kaum erahnen aber bald schon soll hier
eine der größten Windkraft und
Fotovoltaikanlagen der Welt entstehen in
der Steppe Kasachstan herrschen
Windverhältnisse wie auf der Nordsee und
die Sonne scheint wie in Spanien
wir hatten uns überlegt wo in der im
Umkreis von zentral Europa lassen sich
große Projekte realisieren und konnten
eben den Standard hier identifizieren
eben mit den guten Windverhältnissen und
mit der extrem dichten dünnen Besiedlung
wir haben hier Steppe da haben wir ein
sehr geringes Konfliktpotenzial
verglichen eben mit Standorten in
Zentral Europa
heißt das milliardenschwere Projekt
Unterführung der ostdeutschen swb in
Gruppe bereits 2032 wollen die EU in
Deutschland 2 Millionen Tonnen grünen
Wasserstoff importieren Deutschland
ordnet seine Energiebeziehungen neu das
heißt auch wenn du natürlich nach merken
aus denen wir Grünen Wasserstoff
beziehen können seit dem Überfall
Russlands auf die Ukraine versucht die
ehemalige Sowjet Republik Kasachstan auf
Abstand zu Moskau zu gehen und sucht
neue Partner der Besuch des
Bundespräsidenten soll Türen öffnen wenn
wir es ernst meinen dann müssen wir auch
in der Kategorie von Großprojekten
denken und dafür werben dass sich
Unternehmen an solchen Großprojekten
beteiligen es könnte für beide Seiten
eine Win-Win-Situation werden Kasachstan
kann sich mit dem Projekt weiter von
Russland lösen und seine Einnahmen
massiv steigern die EU aber vor allem
Deutschland könnte der heimischen
Industrie grünen Wasserstoff zu
Konkurrenz wegen Preisen bieten bis
dahin ist es aber noch ein weiter Weg
auch der Hafen von kurig dürfte seine
verschlafenen Jahre bald hinter sich
haben künftig soll von hier der grüne
Wasserstoff übers Kaspische Meer nach
Backofen und von dort in Pipelines nach
Europa geleitet werden
im weltweiten Vergleich hat sich die
Gleichstellung von Frauen und Männern in
Deutschland verbessert im Report des
Weltwirtschaftsforums kletterte
Deutschland von Platz 10 auf 6 dies sei
vor allem auf einen höheren Anteil von
Frauen in Parlamenten und Ministerien
zurückzuführen gegenüber 2018 habe aber
die Lohngleichheit insgesamt wieder
abgenommen an der Spitze der 146
Länderliste liegen Island Norwegen und
Finnland
das Zentrum von Paris wurde am
Nachmittag von einer schweren Explosion
erschüttert das betroffene Gebäude
stürzte teilweise ein auch Nachbarhäuser
wurden schwer beschädigt nach ersten
Angaben wurden mindestens 16 Menschen
verletzt sieben davon schwer nach
weiteren Opfern wird noch gesucht wie es
zu der Explosion kam ist noch unklar in
dem Gebäude war eine private Schule für
Design untergebracht
ja im Nordatlantik der wird die Zeit
knapp das vermisste Tauchboot zu finden
Hoffnung macht das ein kanadisches
Suchflugzeug Klopfgeräusche unter Wasser
registrierte Tauchroboter konnten aber
bislang den Ursprung nicht orten die
Titan war am Sonntag zu einer
touristischen Tauchfahrt zum fragt der
gesunkene Titanic aufgebrochen dann nach
knapp zwei Stunden brach der Kontakt zu
den fünf Insassen ab
schauen wir jetzt mal genauer auf unser
Wetter auf sommerliche Hitze folgten
gestern Abend schwere Gewitter und zum
Teil heftige Sturmböen aber das war noch
nichts im Vergleich zu dem was
Meteorologen jetzt erwarten der Deutsche
Wetterdienst spricht von einer
kritischen Wetterlage Christoph
destruell blickt voraus und zurück
der lange sehnte Regen nach der
Trockenheit wie so oft in den letzten
Jahren kommt der zu schnell zu heftig
und mit zu viel Wind im Gepäck
Rüsselsheim in Südhessen gestern Abend
wahrscheinlich war es ein Tornado der
hier Bäume knickte und einem Hochhaus
ein Stück Dach Abriss Bilder vom ersten
unwetterschub der zweite stärkere soll
ab morgen früh von Südwesten aus eine
ganze Reihe von Gewittern bringen
einige davon sind richtig extrem mit 60
bis 90 Liter auf dem Quadratmeter sind
möglich Hagelsturm und Halt orkanböden
und sogar tornados sind drin und zwar
das ist ungewöhnlich potenziell in fast
ganz Deutschland denn mit der kommenden
Unwetterfront ist extrem viel Energie
unterwegs dieses Tief das löst sich erst
einmal nicht auf sondern wandert einfach
ostwärts und das dauert tatsächlich bis
zum Freitag an für die Kanalisation in
Oldenburg bei Bremen war es in der Nacht
schon zu viel Wasser immerhin viel mehr
wird hier oben im Nordwesten nicht mehr
nachkommen was der einzige ungefährdete
Fleck im Land überall sonst gilt Sturm
Hagel Überflutungen spätestens ab morgen
Abend alles denkbar
wilde Wetterlage auch beim Fußball und
dann sind wir beim Sport und Katja das
war nichts gestern in Gelsenkirchen
schon wieder nicht was die Deutschen
also müsste man das Spiel mit einem Wort
beschreiben dann wäre das wahrscheinlich
blamabel die dfbf steckt tief im
krisenmodus nach der erneut Niederlage
dem 0:3 gegen Kolumbien
die Startelf in Gelsenkirchen hat in
sich geballte Champions League Erfahrung
doch im Nationalteam kommt das nicht zur
Geltung die Top-Stars gehen als
Verlierer vom Platz natürlich kann man
sich hinsetzen die Spieler
auseinandernehmen und gute Szenen finden
aber
ja Moment glaube ich ist die Situation
schon dramatisch beim verantwortlichen
Bundestrainer ist nicht für jeden ein
klarer Kurs erkennbar nicht wenige
beginnen ihn in Frage zu stellen der DFB
plant weiter mit ihm irgendwas probiert
wenn was versucht und es ging die Hose
und da ist natürlich kein Trost auch für
die Fans für Fußball Deutschland weil
wir sind die Nationalmannschaft und wir
müssen uns da anders präsentieren der
bundestrain in dem Fall an sie fliegt
ist natürlich dann auch die einzige
sorgen in einem september gegen Japan
und Frankreich dann müssen die spielen
die natürlich wirklich dann auch die
Qualität haben und dann auch eine gute
Europameisterschaft spielen und das
haben muss man sagen ich habe das haben
wir im Moment nicht die startelfingen
Geld in Kirchen kann damit kaum gemeint
sein die hatte es ja in sich das Spiel
geht dennoch 02 verloren ein Jahr vor
der EM im eigenen Land und ein halbes
Jahr nach dem frühen Aus bei der WM in
Katar ist die Nationalmannschaft nicht
weitergekommen
[Musik]
ja wir haben es gehört der DFB steht
weiter zu haben sie fliegt Boris Büchler
beim DFB in Frankfurt wie lange denn
noch
ein Rauswurf ja oder ein Rücktritt sind
aktuell ausgeschlossen die seit heute
Präsident Neuendorf noch einmal
bestätigt nach Telefonaten mit Rudi
Völler und Hansi Flick und natürlich die
Generalkritik von Völler an der Qualität
einiger Spieler das war natürlich zum
Schutze von Bundestrainer Hansi Flick
der DFB braucht langsam mal einen Plan
einen Notfallplan denn sollten auch die
Länderspiele im September gegen
Frankreich und Japan schief gehen dann
kann es eigentlich nur noch personelle
Konsequenzen gehen und die aktuelle Lage
und der aktuelle Plan geht momentan so
in die falsche Richtung dass man sagen
muss ja das könnten Job Endspiele für
hansifik werden wir werden sehen im
September danke schön nach Frankfurt
Boris Büchler
die World Games in Berlin sind ein
großes miteinander vor allem wenn die
juni fight Teams gemeinsam um Medaillen
kämpfen heißt ein beeinträchtigter
Athlet zusammen mit einem nicht
beeinträchtigten so wie heute bei der
Entscheidung im Tischtennis
hochklassige Ballwechsel wie hier von
Günter Ritschel und seinem
unified-partner Daniel strössner gab es
heute bei den Special Olympics in den
Berliner Messehallen zu sehen ja gut
und das hat Spaß gemacht das ist eine
riesen Erfolg auf jeden Fall da wir noch
nicht so lange vielleicht zusammen
spielen wie andere und noch nicht zu
viel Erfahrung gemeinsam haben das
inklusive doppelgewinn nach nur zwei
Jahren gemeinsamen trainingsbranche und
begeistert das Publikum
und bis Sonntag gehen die World Games in
Berlin dann noch Dankeschön Katja so die
gute Nachricht der Sommer geht heute los
also rein astronomisch die schlechte die
Tage werden wieder kürzer der
Sonnenaufgang zur Sommersonnenwende
wurde dieses Jahr wieder groß gefeiert
in Stonehenge in England ein mystischer
Ort der schon vor rund 4.500 Jahren
genau darauf ausgerichtet war und 10.000
Schaulustige waren dabei als die Sonne
exakt hinter dem Eingang zu den
geheimnisvollen Steinkreisen aufgehen
da kein Geheimnis mehr sind die Zahlen
vom Mittwochslotto hier sind sie 6 12 19
22 43 47 und die Superzahl 6 weitere
Infos finden sie auf lotto.zdf.de und
auf der ZDF Text Seite 557
ja die wetteraussicht mit Earth da
Intelli sollten Sie sich genau anschauen
es gibt großes unwetterpotenzial aktuell
gelten Warnungen vor Starkregen Hagel in
Mittelhessen und Süden Niedersachsen
Christian Sievers meldet sich ab 21 Uhr
mit dem heute-journal von uns war es das
für sie heute einen schönen Abend einen
entspannten Abend tschüss
[Musik]
und herzlich willkommen zum Wetter
morgen erwartet uns eine kritische
Wetterlage ein tiefen er hat sich das
ist tief Lambert bringt feuchte und
heiße Luftmassen zu uns und so gibt es
morgen teilweise Regenmengen bis 90
Liter auf den Quadratmeter Hagelkorn
größten von 5 bis 7 cm und sogar
orkanböden bis 130 km pro Stunde sind
drin vereinzelt sogar Tornados schauen
wir uns das Ganze im Detail an von
Südwesten er kommt in der Nacht schon
ordentlich Gewitter Tätigkeit auf hier
schon teilweise Unwetter dabei und
morgen am Vormittag dehnt sich das
Richtung Nordrhein-Westfalen und
Richtung Hessen aus hier schon stark
kriegen dabei ganz im Osten und im
Südosten merkt man nichts dort wird es
aber zum Nachmittag dann ordentlich
krachen hier teilweise auch mit Hagel
Orkanböen und sehr viel Regen in kurzer
Zeit nur ganz im Norden da bleibt es
trocken Temperaturen bis 35 Grad im
Südosten
dreht sich die Luft quasi richtig auf
wird noch mal richtig heiß deutlich
kühler dann im Westen bei 22 Grad die
nächsten Tage werden ruhiger am Freitag
sind nur noch Schauer dabei nicht mehr
so heftig 20 bis 27 Grad und das
Wochenende ist trocken schönen Abend